so Aaron you were able to play the
latest and greatest ground war map for
call of duty modern warfare so how did
it go tell me about this map tell me
about the layout in your experience with
it yes so this is the the last of the
ground war maps it's in a city which is
awesome it reminded me of you know like
the downtown la map from battlefield
hardline and I think because ground war
is gonna pull in so many people from
maybe you know the bit the Battlefield
franchise or people looking for those
bigger maps this had like kind of
everything that I was looking for in one
of these maps so it's a fairly large map
it has skyscrapers and you can get to
the top of almost every building on this
map that's crazy
that's like the last time I can think of
something even close was like a modern
warfare 3 like DLC map pack and that
that map was very cool it's super smart
you know if you give players somewhere
to climb to they're gonna want to do it
because it's honestly just super fun so
here's how it works
you start on each side and you head
towards the the center of jected all of
the objectives are ground-floor I'll
talk a little bit about that later but
when you want to get to the roof almost
every building has a stairwell or
elevators and you can zip up the
elevators once you get on top of the
roof then people you'll see people like
having tons of sniper duels the most
satisfying moment of my life came when I
unlocked a javelin rocket launcher which
has a top-down attack right oh and I
fired it off at a sniper and then was
just like don't see me don't see me
don't see me boom Oh like honestly it is
so much fun getting on the rooftops
maybe maybe a little bit too much fun do
people tend to swarm the skyscrapers as
soon as the game starts is that like are
those the hot spots yeah you see those
classic things like people stealing the
helicopters just to get to the roof but
honestly you don't have to this is one
of the maps where you can get to the
rooftops through the interior of the
buildings so I think after a while
players will kind of learn not to do
that and leave the helicopters for the
more skilled players on top of the
interior spaces on this map you also
have to think a lot more about crossing
the street now because there's so many
people sniping and so many kill streaks
going off so you know look both ways
before you cross the street now in terms
of the objectives if you're not on the
rooftops there's a lot of defense going
on
on this map particularly like the center
see objective where we were at we took
it and then this is where like I think
different styles of play will come in
but there's a there's a pretty big
incentive to actually hang out and hold
objectives it's particularly said our
objectives and it's a little bit easier
to do on this map then the other two
maps people have already played which
tend have very porous Center objectives
I thought the center objectives on this
map slightly like easier to control
lanes and then once you get your kill
streak to rolling you can catch people
coming down alleyways as opposed to just
being inside and having them come at you
from everywhere was there more cover I
felt like it was all open out in the
first and the first two yes so that's
that's an excellent question this
district map has a lot of interior
spaces and a lot of and a lot more cover
alleyways to duck behind that impacts
vehicle play it's much easier to get
taken out because there's just too many
angles to cover in a tank it's tougher
on helicopter pilots although very
satisfying and I got straight sniped out
of a chopper
it's a probably not quite as good for a
lot of the aerial bombardment style
killstreaks so it's better to take
something like sentry gun or your your
equipment the tactical insertion spawn
flare because you you you want your team
or your squad to be able to keep
spawning near and objective you're
trying to hold and the sentry guns are
just way better at covering things like
alleyways good they're more useful I
felt like before it was kind of a
free-for-all but the TAC insertion also
was not unlocked during the beta so
that's really good to hear that it
worked well in this map so the other
thing is there's no vehicle
customization which feels like a missed
opportunity there's they seem afraid to
put guns on helicopters but honestly
like they could get away with it they'd
probably be good for cleaning up
rooftops most players aren't that good
anyway at flying so you'll get a couple
of ace you know God to your pilots but
most people won't won't get that good
another issue with ground war which I
think you know people have noticed and
this is a long-running issue in
battlefield is you never really feel
like you have an impact on whether you
win or lose you are enjoying yourself
but you never really have a concept of
whether you're impacting the final
win-loss ratio unless you get the nuke
we know the nukes in the game so right
people have it it's hard to be the star
then it sounds like I mean it's just
you're just in a swarm of people yeah
all that way right away the exact
opposite of gunfight right you're not
the star of this show you know you're
you're just one soldier in this giant
battle so yeah that's the new map it's a
city map we're really curious how people
feel in general background war so
whether you like this or not really
depends on where you're coming from but
the nice thing is this this Call of Duty
throws a very wide net and my overall
impression is that it's gonna have
something for old fans it's gonna have
something for counter-strike fans it has
something for Battlefield fans tell us
where you're coming from because I think
that's really important thank you so
much Aaron and for more continued
coverage of call of duty modern warfare
keep it right here on GameSpot
[Music]
you